hey guys now some of you have seen me
over these last three years since i
started my youtube channel
going from being shaved to stubble
to a full-on beard
[Music]
some of you asked me in the dms on
social media in the comment section of
the videos
daniel we like the beard how do you do
it how do you maintain it how do you
grow it
a lot of questions so i decided in this
video i'm gonna give you my three
best tips for growing and also
maintaining
a good looking manly beer let's get to
it
i have a dream
[Music]
just very quick if your first time here
on my channel
welcome to dla model lifestyle i'm
daniel if you haven't subscribed yet
then please do and also
click that notification bell and then
you won't miss any of the next
videos now let's start with the first
tip
now the first thing and most important
thing is to just grow out
your beard if you're a beginner and
you're new to growing hair
then don't get scared when you get those
patchy areas just get through that face
your aim is to grow as much hair as you
can to get the length
you want so how do you grow your beard
faster well there's a few things you can
do
first you gotta eat the right kind of
food that will help
your beard to grow healthy fats and
protein like eggs spinach
cinnamon sweet potatoes oysters and
livers
and there then other things that will
help your beard to grow are exercise
exfoliating your skin and then also
beard growth supplements
now remember when you grow out your
beard you will get certain lengths or
phases that you will not like
but you need to push through it to get
to the beard
you want let's move on
second tip you gotta trim your beard
while it's growing
don't cut it just trim it keep it styled
while it's growing out
but don't trim it too much keep it nice
and long and then once you get the
length that you want
then you gotta style it and trim it
always keep your beard
neat number one the hair here below
here or your neck don't let it grow you
gotta cut it
second the hair here on your cheekbones
you wanna shave this off
so you'll have a line going from here
straight down here to the kind of corner
here of your of your mouth
so you see this line going there all the
hair that's above it here on your
cheekbones
get rid of it now remember once you got
your beard to the length
you want it to be all you got to do is
just maintain it and trim it
every now and then some people just
think that your beard will just
automatically
look great once it's grown up it doesn't
work that way it's the same as your hair
here
on the top of your head you need to cut
it trim it style it
it's the same thing with your beard and
you got to remember to trim it the right
way so that it will fit in with your
face shape
so get an adjustable electric shaver
that will work for your beard
for example i like to go from short here
at my ears
and then longer here to my chin and of
course you can try
different beard styles there are many
like the long beard
viking beard pointy beard chin strap
long goatee
the full chin beard van dyke or even the
wolverine beard
there are more styles just take some
time go check it out
and enjoy your beer
the third tip and the last tip is to use
the right beard products the first thing
you got to do is to stay away from
normal shampoo and conditioner that you
use for your hair
why because the hair here on your face
on your cheekbones
your your jaw bones are different than
the ones here on your head and also the
skin i mean your scalp is different here
than the skin on your face
so you need the right beard shampoo and
conditioner or softener
that works for your beard because it
doesn't have so many chemicals in it
and also it will give your beard what it
needs
to look healthy shiny and soft and so
right now i'm trying out a south african
company called
buffles fontaine and no it's not a
sponsored video
i'll talk about a few other brands as
well in a minute so again the first
thing you need is really good beard
shampoo and a softener
conditioner and then very importantly
you need beard oil
so they got these guys i've used them
for a while they're actually pretty good
now you need to know that if you do not
use beard oil your beard will look
and feel dry like grass
add some good beard oil and you will see
and feel the results it will look
healthy
feel soft and you will style it easier
talking about styling
next what you do need is beard balm
which will help you to style your beard
just like pomade for your hair
this is the guy you want for your beard
not only does it help you to style your
beard
but it is actually good for it now
they're very good for you because they
usually contain things like beeswax
cacao butter and
beard oil which is good for your beard
for example buffalo well well they call
it snorrsolf
their language is afrikaans which is my
first language as well
verlbrunder snorsalf it contains
bayavas tlapperwali sandalhotwali which
is beeswax
cacao butter and sandalwood
oil next you need a beard brush and a
beard comb
these guys will help you to keep your
beard neat and styled
it also helps to distribute the oil and
bomb evenly into your whole
beard now of course this is just one
company
called buffles fontaine bard woolly
meaning bethel's fontaine it's like
buffalo
fountain beard oil but other
good quality brands that you can trust
are honest amish jack black and i also
like
viking revolution now of course guys
like always i'll add everything for you
in a video description so you can go and
check it out with their links
so it takes a little bit of time and you
can go and do your own research on it as
well
now if you want your beard to grow
faster and check out this video here
and it's going to help you out i'll see
you there cheers guys